well the fire you've just been watching
is in some ways a metaphor
maybe for the broader decline of
christianity in europe that decline has
been swift
and full of unintended consequences mark
stein has been studying this question
for more than 30 years and we're glad to
have him
with us tonight mark thanks a lot for
coming on there's so many things to say
about this but the one i can't get out
of my mind
is we haven't built anything
like notre dame cathedral in the west in
so long
we don't build things that are beautiful
anymore maybe almost by design
will there ever be anything built like
that ever again
i think we've lost the knack notre dame
is about a
ten minute walk from the pompidou center
uh
named for the late uh president pompidou
and it is
that is one of the ugly like almost
every modern building in paris
that is one of the ugliest things uh
you've ever seen and when you go
back uh eight and a half centuries uh to
the time
when this building began construction it
took a
a century uh for the for the first part
of it to be completed
uh the men who set to work on this knew
that they would not see it finished in
their lifetime
but the uh their their sense of a
transcendent meaning to life was so
strong
uh that the idea of building the most
beautiful uh
buildings to the glory of god uh they
took naturally in a way that
we don't anymore well and that of course
i think
is the reason that they built buildings
like notre dame in the first place
because they were building it
not just for their own amusement but to
glorify god so
this is not and we're not want to be
clear speculating about the cause
of this fire though you know it happened
uh as trace gallagher just noted it at
beginning of holy week
and it is not the only church that has
caught fire in france in the last year
or
you've seen quite a few desecrations of
churches again not saying this is one of
them but give us a sense of the scale of
what's been happening
well well christendom is in retreat in
in europe and
uh in france particularly france has
actually quite an aggressive
uh belief in secularism and
uh according to some polls the french
are even by the standards of the modern
western world among
the the most godless people in that
sense uh
three years ago in that terrible summer
uh
that began with the nice uh truck
killings and when it seemed as if the
entire french state was unraveling
i went to uh ruang cathedral for the
funeral of uh
pair ml uh the the french priest who had
his
throat cut at mass and i then went to
the basilica
of sandini uh which is uh in the north
of paris where the french kings are
buried
and basically is a a a christian museum
in the heart of what is now a a muslim
suburb in effect uh there's no sense of
christianity outside the walls of that
cathedral and it was after that that i
went to then
notre dame because i you do have the
sense
uh that a living breathing faith is just
becoming
actually a museum an art gallery
a storage facility and the french who
were on the streets in tears this
evening on the streets of paris
they're not mourning i don't think
they're mourning just history or
architecture
or art or culture they're mourning
something else but what that's something
else
uh post-christian france uh can't quite
identify it
and that's that's really the conundrum
uh when mr macron says oh we're going to
rebuild it rebuild it for what
uh when people talk about the heart of
france has died
what is in the soul of france what is
this is it just a building or is it
something more
what's so interesting about notron
specifically as you well know
is that it was desanctified
de-christianized
during the french revolution right for a
time and was made a secular temple but
then it immediately reverted to
what it always was which was a christian
holy place will
do you think there's any hope that
something like that will happen again in
france
well i you never know how these things
will go i mean everyone knows the
hunchback of
of notre dame which the victor hugo
novel which actually did
quite a lot to to to restore uh the
importance
of uh notre dame in in the minds of the
french people
but but uh michelle welbeck a a
controversial novelist he wrote a novel
called submission
which posits that france elects a muslim
president and he knows
that the central character knows this is
going to mean something
and he actually makes a conscious effort
to try and recover
his lost catholic faith and that
character goes on a kind of pilgrimage
and and he's moved by it as music and
he's moved by it as ritual
but he can't quite make the final step
and reconnect uh with god and the
catholic faith
and that scene in that book is in a
certain sense the question raised by
this fire tonight
uh is it a hole in the soul or is it
just a missing
building burned to the ground
hasn't made it a better society the
death of christianity
i will say i don't think
good to see you